first we have progress on our
administration's effort to lower the
price of internet for millions of
americans i bet you there are people who
once lived in apartments or still do in
this room who will love this if you
haven't already seen it today the fcc
announced important steps to increase
competition in the market for high-speed
internet which president biden requested
in his executive order on competition as
some of you may know the landlord if you
live in an apartment sometimes requires
you to purchase internet service from
one source and today the fcc voted on a
bipartisan unanimous basis to crack down
on exclusivity agreements between
landlords and internet providers known
as sweetheart deals which lock tenants
and apartments and office buildings into
just one option for internet that might
be good for the landlord uh and for the
internet service provider but bad for
tenants uh bad for american the american
people bad for people living in
apartment buildings who may have to pay
more and accept lower quality service
more than a third of americans live in
apartments and condos and many
businesses operate in multi-tenant
buildings like office buildings or malls
so this is a sweeping problem the fcc is
starting to fix today and second a
competition update that is relevant for
our national security today the
department of defense released a new
report required by the president's
competition executive order explaining
that new actions to promote competition
in defense contracting this report
details that since the 1990s the number
of aerospace and defense prime
contractors has shrunk from 51 to just
five that consolidation means taxpayers
have to pay more for defense services
and it threatens our national security
strength and merger oversight is one of
the five actions the defense department
is taking to address the problem we've
already seen concrete progress on that
front this week on sunday the ftc
successfully blocked lockheed martin's 4
billion attempt to acquire aerojet a
proposed mega merger of major defense
suppliers the ftc had filed the lawsuit
explaining that the merger would jack up
the price the us government has to pay
while delivering lower quality and less
innovation also wanted to note last last
item from me at the top is we're
thrilled uh the senate did its job today
and confirmed the renowned clinical
trialist dr robert kellef once again to
the job of fda commissioner and once
again on a bipartisan basis he brings to
this critical post a lifetime of
knowledge and the institutional
experience that will ensure he hits the
ground running and is guided by the
science on critical missions facing the
fda from continuing to lead the fight
against covid19 to combating the opioid
crisis to ensuring the safety of our
nation's food supply
josh why don't you kick us off thanks
jen
two things on ukraine yes
first markets have obviously already
been reacting to that situation
gasoline prices are up 20 cents a gallon
over the last 30 days on average
is the president saying that if people
are paying more at the pump
that is essentially a direct result of
vladimir putin's actions
and he is to blame for the current burst
we've seen in higher prices
well the president wasn't making a
market assessment or how the market
moves what he was conveying very very
clearly to the american public is that
if russia two were to invade and we were
to put in place uh crippling sanctions
that would have consequences or an
impact here at home so i know that
wasn't exactly how you were asking the
question but that was what he was
conveying in his answer in terms of the
price of gasoline what we've seen is we
know back in december it went down by
about 10 cents thanks to tapping the
strategic petroleum reserve something
where there's still releases that have
been ongoing the president also made
clear in his remarks that he is open to
all options or on the table to help
bring down the price of gasoline but he
wasn't making a market assessment he was
just making clear to the public that if
russia invades and we put in place
crippling sanctions that would have an
impact on the public and then secondly
on ukraine the president talked about
diplomatic efforts yeah if you go into
more detail on what those diplomatic
efforts could be is this going to be
more u.s interaction could there be a
face-to-face meeting with putin and then
how would you define success
under diplomacy is it as simple as
no invasion or are there broader rules
you're looking for given that everything
is now on the table or more things are
on the table
uh sure well on the first part you may
have seen or not that our secretary of
state spoke with foreign minister lavrov
earlier today the president spoke with
uh president macron earlier today as
well i think the readout just went out
to all of you or it should be in your
inboxes as well and what he means by
ongoing diplomacy is that it will
continue uh at the pace and urgency that
you have seen from him over the last
several weeks and from his team and it
is some of it will come from the
president some will come from high-level
members of his national security team
and some of it will come from our
european partners or nato allies who we
remain in very close contact with in
terms of engagement with president putin
uh you as you know he spoke with him on
saturday and he believes in the power of
uh leader to leader diplomacy but i
don't have a prediction of a next
engagement at this point in time and
what about oh sorry
i wanted sorry i didn't get to that last
part of your question um you know how
the we define success is i think how a
lot of our european partners and nato
allies would define it which would be an
uh a de-escalation
a proven de-escalation at the border
of ukraine uh where the russians are
pulling back their troops uh where they
are making clear uh to all to the global
community to the media to the public uh
that they are not invading ukraine and
backing that up with actions
i think following up on on this energy
question in terms of the impact on our
energy which the current president
mentioned and then the consequences here
at home what should americans be
prepared for worst case scenario what
should they expect if this happens
well i think what the president was
touching on um
was the fact that
if russia decides to invade there could
be consequences here at home
and that could have an impact on energy
prices which could have an impact on
prices at the gas pump
and we're taking while we're taking
active steps to alleviate the pressure
on our own energy markets and every
option is on the table to offset rising
prices as you saw the president act last
fall range of options remain on the
table he also wanted to be very clear
and direct with the american people
about what the impact could be and the
fact that in his view defending
democracy and liberty is never without
cost but we need to convey to the
american people exactly what that could
look like one more in russia if
president putin decides not to invade
does president biden consider that a
victory
i think the world the global community
would consider that a victory but again
i think
what the president's view is and what
the national security team's view is is
that this is ultimately up to president
putin and every step we've taken up to
date over the last weeks and even months
to coordinate with our nato allies to
stay in luck in close touch with uh
leaders in congress and members about
what our plans are to put together a um
a crippling sanctions package what we
are doing is we're presenting the choice
to president putin he ultimately is
going to decide which path he chooses go
ahead um i just wanted to close the loop
on um a few things so the the
ukraine has been experiencing a number
of cyber attacks today um
a number of its banks were affected the
defense ministry was affected
has the united states attributed those
attacks to russia
uh i don't have anything on the
attribution at this point in time i know
there have been a range of reports uh
what i can say is that um we have been
in touch with the ukrainians
our allies and partners
working with them to deter and respond
to malicious cyber activity we have also
been warning for weeks and months both
publicly and in our engagements with the
ukrainians as well as our european
partners about the potential for russia
to conduct cyber operations in ukraine
but i don't have anything more specific
on attribution at this point okay and
just you know kind of moving a little
bit into the realm of the hypothetical
there are a lot of steps oh boy i know
there are a lot of steps that russia
could take that are short of an invasion
but there are still
um you know aggressive um you know
including cyber including um there's
this um uh step that their congress has
taken on recognizing these breakaway
regions in ukraine as as being you know
a separatist legitimately and separatist
regions um would the u.s respond to any
any things like that with sanctions as
you would to you know an actual invasion
we have conveyed before and i'll
reiterate now that we would be prepared
to respond uh with a range of malicious
activities or actions that the russians
were to take okay one more thing i know
that um
you there's you know you've said that
there's very little daylight with you
and european allies on this issue
the german chancellor said today that
ukraine joining nato is
simply not on the table it's not on an
agenda item right now is that how you
would characterize it from from the
white house well i think as you've heard
the president convey you just heard him
convey in his remarks uh our view from
the united states is that nations have
the right to sovereignty to territorial
integrity freedom to set their own
course and choose who they associate
with so we the united states we're never
going to pressure ukraine or any country
to join or not join a global alliance
that is up to them and up to the
other members of nato
go ahead uh thanks jen just you say all
options are on the table let's be more
specific on the possibility of a gas tax
holiday with the white house support
doing that
i have nothing to predict for you at
this point uh but all options remain on
the table he said in his speech uh if
russia attacks americans in ukraine
we will respond is there specific
intelligence suggesting that some kind
of targeted attack on americans in
ukraine
i don't think he was suggesting that i
think as we've conveyed as we've warned
uh and been very clear about the risk
that would be posed to anyone who's in
ukraine including american citizens or
russia to invade one of the biggest
militaries in the world that there would
be serious risks to civilians that's i
think what he was conveying with the
ukrainian president slated to be out of
his country this weekend into the munich
security conference um
you must think that's a good idea for
him to be gone right now
i don't think we have an assessment on
that from here uh obviously the munich
security conference is an opportunity
for any leader to uh engage with
communicate with
other leaders in the world and obviously
the vice president is going as you know
got a busy day obviously with ukraine
but has the president talked to any
supreme court nominee have any
interviews been scheduled we're going to
disappoint you here ed um and just
convey that i think we're not going to
give day-to-day updates from here uh
moving forward about whether or not he's
done interviews
what i can confirm for you is we're
still on track to uh for the president
to make a decision and make an
announcement uh before the end of the
month which is in two weeks
he will do some interviews in the next
two weeks that's what i can confirm for
you go ahead jackie thanks jen um
we've been told for a long time that
some cyber attacks would likely precede
an invasion um so if it turns out that
russia is behind what happened today
um or is i guess i should phrase it is
is there work being done
quickly to figure out if russia is
behind what happened today so that
sanctions can be imposed before there is
bloodshed or is the calculus still sort
of centering on
force on force or some you know passing
over they sure well we are constantly
doing those assessments and certainly as
any cyber attack happens that is
certainly a process that happens uh
behind the scenes and that our
intelligence community and our national
security community undertakes as it
would be in this case as well i would
note though as it relates to sanctions
one there's a range of means uh that we
could uh respond uh both seen and unseen
so it's to a cyber attack or any other
attack and the president has the purview
to do uh whatever he chooses in that
regard but our view remains that uh the
crippling package of sanctions is an
effective deterrent so if you do that
all in advance uh what is to stop them
from
moving forward now that may have to be a
different of policy issue a different uh
opinion i should say on policy issues
with uh some in congress and that's okay
but that is our view from the
administration
and then this may or may not be related
at all but is there any information on
what caused the power outage on the
north lawn i mean every tv network lost
power at the same time during a very
inconvenient time i will just note for
all of you and for us um i don't have
any assessment of that no or yes
does the white house view um ukraine
giving up on nato aspirations as a
possible op-ramp i understand that you
know the president has said the
administration has said over and over
that
nato members would not um you know
encourage or would not give up that
ability uh
for someone else to join but you know
they do have a long way to go
and now that there is you know all of
this concern that if there was a member
if they did become members it could
potentially trigger article five is
there any discussion um among nato
allies about you know
how significant it would be if zielinski
were to
make that offer himself
well we have not raised that um from the
united states um and again i would
reiterate what i said a little bit
earlier which is that our position is
that we are not going to pressure
ukraine or any country to join or not
join
an alliance that it is uh nations have
the right to sovereignty and territorial
integrity and uh that's a choice for
them to make
why is the administration
encouraging americans who are the fact
that or fleeing through poland um to be
to bring proof of coping 19 vaccination
as i understand it poland does not
require that so is there going to be
a shift in messaging
for americans who are trying to get out
through poland
i would check with the state department
on that i'm happy to follow up with you
for you on your behalf as well go ahead
thank you so much jen i i want to circle
back to the idea of what de-escalation
would look like and how the
administration would trust that it were
actually real do you have a sense of how
many troops you would need to actually
see with your own eyes through satellite
images or otherwise would need to
withdraw in order for this
administration to feel as though putin
were in fact
well i think kristin that is a decision
that we would make in partnership with
our nato allies right and european
countries and you look at everything
from satellite imagery something that
many of you have
access to uh to validation and
verification of what they're saying they
would do so i i can't i'm not go and i'm
not going to be in a position
or what i expect the defense department
would be to give you a troop number but
i think it will would be very clear if
that were a step they were taking okay
and i think there have been a lot of
mixed messages publicly coming out today
among them the nato secretary general
said that there is cause for cautious
optimism when it comes to some of these
talks that are happening behind the
scenes does the administration does the
president share that cautious optimism
because we heard from the president very
firm language
well the president also conveyed it
would be positive if it was verified
that they pulled back their troops and
uh certainly the openness to diplomacy
is something that um everybody should
support and i think our nato allies
would support as well at the same time
we've seen this playbook before and
especially given uh the history of
president putin and the russians
their their history of false flag
operations of misinformation
we need to verify so and i guess that's
my question does the administration
share the nato secretary general's
cautious optimism
i think i'm not gonna i don't think we
need to put in uh more words than what
the president just conveyed in a speech
to the country gop senators have
unveiled a sanctions bill
have you assessed whether or not this is
something the administration wants to
see some movement on is it something
that you uh would potentially support
even that the bipartisan talks stalled
not yet because it just came out but
again our view remains that a bipartisan
effort would be the best effort moving
forward and as i conveyed to jackie a
few minutes ago you know our view
continues to be that the crippling
sanctions package we've designed is
meant to be a deterrent
jen the senate's working on this stop
gap funding bill you know the deadline
is friday
what's the level of confidence that
the president will be able to sign that
extension by friday and separately
because the administration been talking
to the two republican senators who
uh raised concerns senator
senator lee and blackburn
uh we we are engaged with a range of
democrats and republicans and certainly
uh we are hopeful that we will be able
to sign this um i would note though that
i believe and correct me if i'm wrong
here that one of senator blackburn's
primary concerns is about a relation to
the set to the funding of crack pipes is
this correct which is not an issue so
this is a this is an issue that what is
happening here is its potential to hold
up funding the government and important
programs around an issue that is not an
issue because we've been very clear that
we are not providing funding for crack
pipes and then the senate banking
committee had planned to vote on your
fed nominees today
there was a hold up there republicans
have been objected to
sarah bloom raskin's nomination
what does the administration think of
this delay
and is the administration going to
provide any additional details to
senator toomey some of the issues that
he's raised
well let me first say that this is in a
very extreme step that's totally
irresponsible in our view it's never
been more important to have confirmed
leadership at the fed to help continue
our recovery and fight inflation and
obviously they have a
unique role to play an important vital
role to play as it relates to inflation
and i think democrats and republicans
have agreed on that for decades so
republicans are out there saying
inflation's a problem it's a huge issue
we agree and then they're not even
bothering to show up to even vote
against these nominees to the federal
reserve what message is that sending to
the american public so uh we and i would
note just on sarah bloom raskin since
you asked me about her as well she's one
of the most qualified individuals to
ever be nominated to the federal reserve
she's made
the strongest ethics commitment in the
history of the fed even as she's made
extensive disclosures to the banking
committee as a natural part of the
process senator toomey has continued to
promote false allegations that have
already been shot down by ethics experts
the kansas city fed the founder of the
reserve trust and sarah bloom raskin
herself so we're going to continue to
work with chairman brown on a path
forward and look forward to the banking
committee eventually holding a vote to
commit these uh to confirm these five
nominees
is there any entertaining of other
options if it stalls in committee you
know this appears to be some question
about whether the senate as a whole can
advance these nominations is that
something you're exploring or is that
something that you don't think you have
the power to do
we are you mean in terms of different
legislative processes or different
speculation that the
full senate could uh sort of skip the
committee vote if it stalls out and
bring them forward sure
do you believe that the senate has that
power award
through committee our focus right now is
on working with chairman brown on on
moving these nominees through the
committee can i ask also
hhs briefed congress uh this week uh
we're putting 30 billion in funding can
you give a defensive aid from that be
what in particular do you need this
funding for and has the existing funding
been allocated sure so um
hhs briefing uh today or this afternoon
was a part of our regular conversations
with congress about various resources is
need including uh what is needed for
coveted response uh this is important
because while we continue to have
sufficient funds to respond to the
current omicron surge in the coming
weeks our goal has always been to ensure
that we are well prepared to stay ahead
of the virus so we've been in these
ongoing conversations about what those
needs might look like and this was a
part of that effort
in terms of funds that have been
allocated or spent more than 90 percent
so available rescue plan funds which is
where the funding has come from to date
have been obligated or allocated
90 of that has been for purchases of
vaccines and therapeutics vaccine
distribution efforts that have gotten
shots and arms testing including for
schools and at other high-need locations
uh resources from the rescue family and
prior coveted response bills have
enabled us to respond forcefully to the
delta and omicron surges and what we're
trying to do now is uh stay ahead uh and
and stay in in contact with congress
about what those needs might look like
secretary lincoln said yesterday that
the us is not on pace right now to meet
the president's goal the whole goal
of vaccinating 70 of the world by later
this year is any of this funding aimed
at jump starting global
vaccination efforts and can you talk a
little bit about why you know on pace is
it for instance a supply problem or is
it a problem with
uh what what secretary lincoln called
last mile type stuff getting shots in
hearts to borrow the language of the
company that is that is an undervalued
part of it i should say so i thank you
for raising that part of it so right now
we've shipped over around 440 million
doses and are continuing to aggressively
share around 10 million doses a week to
the world free of charge we're the first
country to buy doses for the sole
purpose of sharing them with the world
we also bought as you know a billion
doses
and secretary blinken i think made those
comments in part because he wants to
rally the world to do more uh but a big
part of our effort right now um and and
we're where we have seen challenge is
turning vaccines uh into vaccination
which means working closely with our
partners on the ground and dealing with
hyper local issues countries may be
facing to increase vaccination and this
is a big part of the focus of ambassador
power and usaid's global vaccination
initiative but part of it is is that
shots and arms components
because the capacity is the problem more
than the supply there have been moments
yes where countries are not able to
receive um the doses that we're able to
provide
go ahead thank you um
creating a gas tax holiday takes
legislation yes and i'm wondering
what are other things that the president
can do on his own
to mitigate uh gas price height because
of
ukrainian conflict
what else can he do by himself and in
terms of releasing uh oil from the spr
have you made a determination of how
much
uh
cost rise that would offset in other
words what good does it do sure um
that's a good question and those are
assessments that our economic team is
constantly of course making um we did
see even the anticipation of the release
back in december helped lower the price
by about 10 cents
but
those assessments are are constantly
being made in terms of without a
decision being made which i know you're
not asking but just to be clear um
there are steps the president has taken
in the past
[Music]
will continue to do uh because clearly
we need to ensure that the supply out in
the global market is meeting the demand
and obviously
correct yes and that's been a part of
our effort uh even as we anticipate what
what impact there could be from an
invasion so as you know there's
obviously a difference between natural
gas shortages and the impact on home
heating which is largely a regional
issue but we have been still in europe
but we've been still working with
partners uh on that as well uh but also
on the supply of gas out in the market
oh well i should say for gas she'll go
ahead um the president said that an
invasion remains distinctly possible
some senior administration could have
said
a couple days ago that as soon as this
week is that still the timeline or has
anything shifted based on the kind of
mixed messages of the last couple days
we don't have a new assessment
as i think you heard the president say
um it's there's a
distinct possibility but we don't have a
new assessment of a decision being made
either and then i know there's been
internal discussions about giving a
speech like the one the president had
today for some time
why today
and then the intent behind it obviously
seemed to be looking to hit on multiple
audiences to deliver specific messages
to them so why today why that
range of messages
you know philip phil i mean you all have
been covering this very closely the
potential of an invasion our diplomatic
engagements and there's no question the
american people have been consuming what
you have been reporting uh but i think
we felt and the president felt it was
important to
be very clear and direct with the
american people about what the impact
could be on them
what the consequences would be
what our values are and why it is
important to stand by
not just the territorial integrity and
sovereignty of a country uh but also uh
stand among our our allies and partners
around the world so it was very
important to him uh to lay out very
clearly uh what's the steps we've taken
the actions we're prepared to take
what's at stake for the united states
and the world and how this will impact
us here at home in terms of why today it
wasn't based on obviously as you saw a
desire to put out a new policy or based
on
something new internally it was uh just
our the president's interest in and
feeling it was time to speak directly to
the american people about all of those
issues this last one on the first point
that you made there is there concern
either by the president or inside the
white house that perhaps um the
understanding or support for kind of
traditional western alliances that have
been a pillar of the last 80 years is
waning or doesn't exist to the degree
that it used to
i think
yeah no it's a good question i don't
have any data assessment of that but we
also are fully aware of the fact that
right now the american people are still
grappling with a pandemic they're
grappling with rising costs some two-ish
two big issues the president speaks to
quite frequently
and it was important to him to be able
to lay out clearly for them what this uh
you know potential conflict potential
invasion uh in in a place that may feel
far away and how could impact them how
that could impact them and his
engagement go ahead
thank you jen uh president biden today
said there's 150 000 uh russian troops
encircling ukraine that appeared to be a
higher number than previously reported i
think 130 000 is how most recently
we've seen it characterize so was the
president confirming an actual
escalation of russian troops
or
why did he present a new number there
well i think over the last
dozen days or so we've seen a dramatic
acceleration and build up of troops um
and so the president said in his remarks
very carefully uh it's encircling
ukraine on the border and also in
belarus uh and so i think he felt it was
important to give an assessment of where
things stand secondly regarding a gas
tax holiday you said quote all options
remain on the table there is right now a
bill from senate democrats uh that would
institute a uh
suspension of the gas tax for the rest
of the year does the white house support
that specific bill we haven't made any
decision about additional steps at this
point in time
great thanks jen two questions um as you
mentioned earlier vice president harris
is headed to the munich security
conference this week does the president
plan to also send secretary blinken and
if so would a last-minute edition
suggest a different or perhaps reduced
or more limited role for vice president
harris at that time
i don't think there's any plans to limit
or reduce the vice president's role at
the munich security conference or at the
global stage on a global stage she's
going to give a speech while she's there
and she is a vital and important
representative for the united states and
our values
and our intentions at this point
in the world
but uh in terms of plans for secretary
blinken to attend or not i i can check
with the state department see there are
plenty of leaders to meet with so
more bandwidth on a different note the
president continues to talk about his
buildback better plan he did stuff today
did a couple of events last week what is
the white house expectation at this
point about the future of that plan is
there any evidence of any sort of
forward movement or progress even on a
on a paired back version of that there
doesn't seem to be a lot of optimism or
action right now on capitol hill but can
you talk about what the white house
expectation is for that and why the
president continues to bring this up
well the president continues to bring it
up because as we talk about the impact
of inflation which most people
experience in their daily lives as
rising costs one of the ways that we can
address that is by passing
legislation that will help lower costs
for americans whether it's child care or
health care or the cost of prescription
drugs and we can do that and fully pay
for it by making the tax system more
fair so what is encouraging to the
president um is that there is broad
support for lowering costs for the
american people in all of those
categories and for making the tax system
more fair and we are continuing to work
in step and in partnership with a range
of senators and they're having their own
discussions about moving uh these
efforts forward
go ahead thank you very much jen uh one
question on asian americans and one
question on ukraine asian americans
actually the king usa gold medal winner
chloe kim revealed as an asian-american
according to ap quote she was tormented
online daily she said she was concealed
by the fear that her parents could be
killed whenever she heard the news about
another brutal assault
and asian person uncle actually under a
prison biden's watch in
2021 the anti-asian hate crimes
increased by 339
it seems we don't see much action taken
by the white house and even in a press
briefing
the very last time you mentioned about
asian americans was less men
so will the president take
some action or even just record a video
like what he did last year to raise the
awareness well let me say first that
chloe kim i'm obsessed with the olympics
so i'm just gonna give you a little
biography here but um she's 21 years old
and she made those comments which is
incredibly courageous and brave that she
spoke out about the fear she had the
fear she has for her family members and
she's not the only asian american to do
that but she is somebody who is now a
double gold medalist amazing um and so i
just want to take a moment to applaud
her for her courage in doing that i will
say that the president
has put in place a task force he has
hired a senior level staffer to be a
representative and be someone who can
speak to these threats and these
concerns and these fears felt by the
asian american community because there's
a number of steps we need to take and
continue to take to address and we've
seen this rise unfortunately because of
hate-filled rhetoric and language around
the uh the origins of the pandemic
and that is something that
asian-americans across the country have
been feeling so i can just reiterate for
you that the president is absolutely
committed to continuing to speak out to
crack down to take steps um and and
again would thank chloe kim for her
courage go ahead okay
president biden said that we should give
diplomacy every chance to succeed
secretary blinken after his call with
foreign minister lavrov said that a
window remains open to resolve this
peacefully i just on the timeline how
long does the president think that
window should stay open if there's no
invasion but also no pullback of russian
troops
well what's the alternative if we don't
leave the
open the window to diplomacy open
right i mean you know our objective
obviously is you heard the president say
today there is no threat the united
states is posing to russia to the
russian people there's no threat uh that
ukraine is posing to russia what we're
working to do here is leave a forum for
de-escalation for uh and prevent a war
and so for up to us the door to
diplomacy should always be open and we
should always look for opportunities to
de-escalate is there any concern this
turns into like a frozen conflict
basically where troops just stay on the
border and there's no invasion but also
no pullback well again uh there's going
to have to be a continued dialogue and
discussion but russia not invading
ukraine and not uh risking uh and
impacting uh the lives of many many
people in that country including
potentially american citizens would
certainly be a step we would welcome
what americans should prepare for you
mentioned the threat of cyber attacks
the president mentioned that as well and
we know homeland security is previously
mentioned they've seen an uptick in
scanning on u.s criminal critical
infrastructure and so on should
americans be prepared for a potential
russian cyber attack on critical u.s
infrastructure for other networks well i
would say even before we've been
discussing um the
the build up of troops at the border and
even before we've been discussing the
bellicose rhetoric
we have seen an uptick in cyber
activity
by malicious actors around the world
either those living in countries or the
countries themselves um and so that is
something i don't have any new threat or
new warning to pose today uh but that is
something we have certainly been
amping and increasing our focus on as an
as a threat that's emerging but has been
the case for the last several years can
you take your question on africa uh yeah
one second go ahead and then i'll go jen
just this hour lawmakers put out a
bipartisan statement warning president
putin i know you've said from the podium
that the white house doesn't need
congress to pass a sanctions package to
implement your own sanctions package but
wouldn't it have sent a stronger message
if there had been an agreement reached
what message do you think it sends to
putin that all we got out of congress
was a statement
i think president putin knows very
clearly because he's heard it directly
from president biden's mouth that if he
invades uh if he invades ukraine that
there will be crippling sanctions and we
don't need congress to act in order to
do that and when will the president make
a decision on
any new energy policies to impact prices
at the pump because even without an
invasion prices have risen beyond where
they were before the emergency reserve
released back in november you're right
and the president is very focused on
making sure we're doing everything we
can to lower the cost uh for americans
uh in any way it hits them whether it's
prices at the pump or when you go buy a
pound of meat uh or wherever it may be
so we're continuing to assess and he's
continuing to look at options i don't
have a prediction of of any decision
though
go ahead
i'll go to you after simon quinn
switching topics entirely the president
is headed later this week to ohio he
said that he'd like to be out in
communities with people yeah frequently
how often would he like to be out there
per week what do you guys rant every day
well
but when he says that what is your
anticipation is he looking to travel two
three days a week and when would you
expect that to ramp up
you know i think you can expect that to
increase around the state of the union
and after um and uh i think we are
constrained by a couple of things
including the cr funding but also
the fact that there is a whole lot going
on in the world um even though he can be
president anywhere uh he also has a
responsibility to sometimes be in the
white house uh or oftentimes be in the
white house so but he's looking forward
to getting out there more in the coming
weeks does he have anywhere specific
that he hasn't been yet or places that
he hasn't been that he feels frequently
enough that he'd really like to get back
to
uh good question i i would venture to
guess that um he has probably been
nearly everywhere given he ran for
president a couple times and vice
president
as president i don't have any prediction
of states or at readout of states that
he's looking forward to going to but i
i'm sure he he is looking forward to
traveling around the country blue states
red states across the gamut go ahead
okay okay simon i'll call you go ahead
simon okay thank you thank you it's been
three months so if you can allow me to
ask two questions
that the president spoke with prime
minister abby ahmed
of ethiopia on january that it's been
almost in months now more than a month
since that took place and the who
yesterday released a statement saying
that the state don't have access to the
tea gravy job for humanitarian access
because the government is not allowing
them to have fuel so is the president
still interested in anything else apart
from ukraine
uh of course he is um the president uh
has to uh be the a global leader in the
world uh and he is responsible for not
just what's happening around the world
but also what's happening domestically
let me give you an update or a comment
from here we're hopeful that recent
steps taken by the government of
ethiopia and other actors might open a
path to resolving the conflict over the
last month the prime minister has taken
steps to promote dialogue release
political prisoners and enable expanded
delivery of medical supplies in the
tigray region we continue to have
serious concerns about the humanitarian
situation in ethiopia and we are focused
on working with our parties with all
parties to end the source of the
suffering the military conflict go ahead
karen
president olympia tomorrow or is calling
for a day of unity a national holiday
tomorrow in ukraine his message for the
last couple of days if not longer has
been don't panic to ukrainians does the
administration have concerns that
zielinski and ukraine leaders have not
adequately prepared the ukrainian people
for a russian invasion
well i'm not going to speak to that what
i can speak to is what we feel our role
in responsibility is which is to provide
a range of information about uh what we
see at the border
what we see russia preparing and our
assessment of what impact that could be
every leader makes their own decisions
do you have an update on the
humanitarian assistance that the us is
talking with european allies should that
happen and the ukrainian people need
that sure i know we uh secretary blinken
made an announcement i believe it was
yesterday about um additional
um assistance let me just see if i have
any more details on in here and if not i
will get that to you shortly after the
briefing karen let me just see
um
let's see here
let me get you i can get you let's see
last no so we we did offer we just
announced sorry a sovereign loan
guaranteed ukraine of up to one billion
dollars to bolster ukraine's economy
amidst pressure resulting from russia's
military buildup this build on the three
billion in sovereign loan guarantees we
issued to ukraine between 2014 and 2016.
we've also committed more security
assistance to ukraine in the last year
than at any point in history 650
million and we also announced we're
launching a new partnership fund for
resilient ukraine with our european uh
with our allies and partners
to include to continue to expand on that
the last thing is we the export-import
bank has made available three billion
dollars in support for projects in
ukraine and the development finance
corporation has a current investment
portfolio in ukraine of approximately
800 million dollars across more than a
dozen projects so we've obviously
provided a range of assistance which we
will continue to build on go ahead
jen will vice president harris be
meeting with president
when she's in munich i don't have
anything on her planned meetings at this
point in time i expect we'll have more
as we get a little bit closer and and i
expect they'll do a preview call from
her team as well and then an olympics
question yeah does the administration
have any reaction to the ioc's decision
to allow russian figure skater and
what's her name camilla balila to
continue competing in the olympics after
joking scandal
uh well i would point you to the
statement made by the u.s olympic and
paralympic committee who opposed the
decision made in beijing saying it
appears to be another chapter in the
systemic and pervasive disregard for
clean sport by russia but these were
independent decisions made by the u.s
anti-doping agency and court of
arbitration for sport we don't have any
additional comment from here i would
point you again to the u.s olympic
committee
so the u.s energy information
administration shows data that russian
oil being imported in the u.s has been
increasing over the past year may of
2021 it was the most on record now the
president said he's wants to use all
tools to keep gas prices down is it is
he looking at temporary things to keep
gas prices down should there be a
russian invasion or is there any
consideration in reversing some of the
policies and going back to increasing
u.s energy independence
uh i don't have anything to uh detail
for you include in terms of what he is
considering but our overarching
objective is to inc decrease the impact
on american consumers and increase the
impact on uh russian leaders we talked
about the boycott on the republicans of
the fed nominees does the white house
support allowing four of the five
nominees to go through and then dealing
with cerebrum ratskin later
again we are working with uh with
chairman brown uh to move all five
nominees forward uh go ahead right there
go ahead yeah thanks jen um do you have
any update on maybe steps the white
house is taking in the event that the
trucker protesting in canada heads to
the us and also especially to d.c around
the time of the state of the union uh
well we our department of homeland
security team has been assessing and i
gave an update last week that they also
increased support uh federal support uh
around the super bowl when there were
those reports i would note the super
bowl did move forward and there was no
um no halting of that so that is a
positive development
as well but we are constantly assessing
any impacts or any any uh security
impacts but i don't have anything to
preview for you
go ahead thanks john i wanted to ask
back to the supreme court the president
received a report with recommendations
on how to reform the supreme court
late last year has he at all reviewed
the report yet and taken a position on
it uh it wasn't uh it wasn't i just
remind everyone it wasn't
recommendations it was a broad
assessment from across the
gambit of um
scholars from from all ends of the
political spectrum
who were looking at a range of historic
issues as it relates to the court the
president has been reviewing that but i
don't have anything to uh read out for
you on that front thing i wanted to ask
you was about voting rights um the
president signed this expansive
executive order a year ago on voting um
i believe susan rice put out
on it in september or october um could
you provide an update on what agencies
are doing we're going to start beginning
seeing elections as soon as next month
um i believe that's in texas but other
states are going to start to have them
yes i do have a lot on this not in front
of me so in terms of what agencies are
working on or what they've been working
on and what they've basically been doing
so you have more detail on this than
maybe others do but um all of the
agencies were tasked with putting
together their own plans to expand
voting access and they've been working
on those plans they're all at different
points in the review process uh and how
it will be implemented
but if you look at it past examples
where i think it was back in the 90s
where if you went to the dmv to renew
your driver's license they would offer
you the opportunity to register to vote
you know stuff like that but let me see
if we can get you something and anyone
else who's interested after the briefing
okay we'll do one more and then we'll
wrap it up go ahead thank you so much
one on china one on afghanistan first of
all china's foreign ministry has been
really critical of us rhetoric on the
russia ukraine crisis calling it hyping
up the possibility of warfare saying the
us is clamoring for block confrontation
confrontation what does the white house
make of this rhetoric are you going to
take any action against either through
talk or other means and what do you make
of this closeness between mossville and
beijing
well i would say that the first the
meeting that they had a couple of weeks
ago reflects an approach both countries
have already taken for some time which
is to move closer together we know and
we've said before but china is not in a
position to compensate russia for their
economic
losses and we have tools to deploy if we
see foreign companies including those in
china trying to backfill sanctions uh
you know i would say our overarching
view though is that if russia chooses to
move forward um it will cost china and
how it's viewed in the eyes of europe
and the world and that's something for
them to assess um we
are trying to prevent a war here
that is why we are putting information
out and why we are engaging with the
global community how do you respond to
afghans who are critical of the
executive order that proposes to split
the the frozen afghan money they say
that you know they weren't involved in
the 911 attacks so why are they getting
less of these funds that they're
entitled to
well i would say that first um
in order for just let me start with the
fact that um this is one step in the
process no funds can be transferred
until the courts make a ruling uh what
the president was trying to do was
enable certain us-based assets belonging
to afghanistan's central bank to be used
to benefit the afghan people otherwise
it would have been held right and that
from money wouldn't have been going and
so that that's why we saw and he took a
proactive step to facilitate access to
3.5 billion of those assets for the
benefit of the afghan people and
afghanistan's future um more than as you
know uh many u.s victims of terrorism
including the relatives of victims who
died in the september 11th terrorist
attacks have have brought claims against
the taliban and are pursuing these
assets in federal court so more than
35.5 billion in assets are going to
remain in the united states and are
subject to the ongoing litigation but i
think it's important for people to know
and understand is he took this proactive
step to sign the executive order in an
effort to try to uh provide some of this
funding to the afghan people
the courts have to rule in order for it
to happen
3.5 billion dollars right the court that
has it has to the courts have to rule in
order for any of the funding to move
forward i believe
how's that
he's making clear that he believes that
half of the funding should go to the
afghan people to for humanitarian
purposes thanks everyone
i think i answered that question a
little bit earlier
you